لقد سرقت ما قيمته حوالي ألفي ونصف
ألف دولار من نقاط الفنادق
، والأسوأ من ذلك كله أنك وضعتني في
منتصف الطريق يا إلهي وقد سمحوا
لك بفعل ذلك ، لذا فأنا هنا في لاس فيغاس
لأكبر اثنين في العالم
مؤتمرات القرصنة ولسبب ما
وافقت على الاختراق ،
أقابل راشيل توباك
المتخصصة في شكل خاص من القرصنة
يسمى الهندسة الاجتماعية وأشعر
بالتوتر الشديد وأشعر أنني أعرف
كل شيء عنك إلى حد كبير لا أفعله على الفور
أثق بك ، لذا سأكون أكثر أمانًا اليوم
بفضلك أنت وكل
عميل آخر سيكون أكثر أمانًا اليوم بفضل
ما ترغب في السماح لي بالقيام به بشكل جيد ،
دعنا نبدأ على ما أعتقد ، لذا فأنت
تريد أن تفترض أن كل شيء
ترتديه  وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي هي
معلومات عامة يمكن العثور عليها في أماكن
مثل هذه ويمكن استخدامها
لمصادقتك مع شركات مختلفة ، هل
تتذكر هذه التغريدة ، نعم ، لقد استخدمت هذا
للوصول إلى عنوانك الحالي ،
فما فعلته هو أنني استدعيت هذا
الأثاث  شركة ture هنا
وقلت بشكل أساسي ، سنشتري
قطعة أخرى من قطع الأثاث هذه
ولكني بحاجة للتأكد من أنني لا
أمتلك المعلومات الخاطئة
في الحساب عن طريق الخطأ وقالوا لا ، أعني
أنك طلبت شيئًا لفترة  منذ ما مضى ولكن
الشيء الذي طلبته قمنا بشحنه إلى
هذا العنوان ونعم أعتقد أنني حصلت
على عنوانه المحدث وهو أمر
مخيف جدًا لأنه حدث في 30 ثانية لقد تلقيت
عنوانك الحالي
لقد تلقيت عيد ميلادك أنا تويتر اتصلت
به إلى حد كبير كل  العمل الذي
أدرجه في أي وقت مضى والذي استخدمه على Twitter
أو Instagram الخاص به ، ما عليك أن تفهمه
هو عندما تفعل ذلك ، فأنا الآن أعرف
الشركات التي تستخدمها وأعرف
الشركات التي استقبلت مكالماتك كما
حصلت على رقم هاتفك من الفندق البوتيك
وقد أعطوك رقم هاتفي ،
لذا سأقوم بإجراء هذه
المكالمات الهاتفية ، سأكون في الواقع قرصنة حية ،
لذلك عندما أتصل برقم هاتفك ،
سيظهر على المتصل
من أنت حقًا
مهما كنت  د لأعرف أن هذا حقًا
هو سبب وجودي على الطريق
الآن وأواجه مشكلة في الوصول
إلى الإنترنت الخاص بي ، لكنني بحاجة إلى تحويل
النقاط إلى صديقي لحضور حفل زفاف ،
آمل أن تتمكن من مساعدتي عبر
الهاتف الذي أملكه جميعًا  المعلومات التي لديّ
تسعين ألفًا صحيحة ، لذا فإن
الاسم الأول والأخير هو راشيل توباك
، لقد تم نقلهما ، حسنًا ،
شكرًا لك يومًا رائعًا وداعًا ،
لقد اختفت نقاطك ، هذا
جنون عندما تتصل بشركة الطيران هذه
سيأتي من رقمي نعم نعم
أنت تعلم أنني أعيش في فيغاس ، سأضعك
في المنتصف أحاول أن أفعل هذا
كشيء مقال شخصي ، لذا يمكنك نقلي
إلى المقعد الأوسط نوعًا ما في الجزء الخلفي
من  طائرة أعلم أنك ربما لا تحصل على
هذا الطلب كثيرًا ، حسنًا ، حسنًا ،
إنه صف قبل الصف الأخير مباشرة
وهو في المقعد الأوسط ، أنت في الجزء
الخلفي من المقعد الأوسط بالطائرة كان
لدي ممر خروج وأنا أعلم أنه  التقطت قائلة السيد
أوسوليفان كيف يمكنني مساعدتك إذا لم
أكن جالسًا  g هنا معك ولم
يعرفوا أنهم قالوا جيدًا سيدي ، لقد
اتصلت وطلبت ذلك ، سأقلب
[موسيقى]
فكر في مقدار ما عليك القيام به
للدخول إلى حساباتك عبر الإنترنت ،
يجب أن يكون لديك كلمة مرور مكونة من
عاملين '  إعادة العيش في العصور المظلمة
على الهاتف مقارنةً بمدى
صعوبة اقتحام الحسابات عبر الإنترنت حتى
تتعلم هذه الشركات تغيير
بروتوكولات المصادقة الخاصة بها ، فهناك
بعض الأشياء التي يمكنك القيام بها للمساعدة في
حماية
نفسك وإزالة علامات تحديد الموقع الجغرافي الخاصة بك عند
استخدام Instagram Twitter  Facebook
ليس هناك حاجة لأن يعرف الأشخاص بالضبط
مكان إقامتك في تلك الأماكن
بعد ذلك ، أود أن أقول إن المنتجات التي
تشتريها من الخدمات التي اشتريتها تساعد في
محاولة الاتصال بالإنترنت مثل
Twitter والتي ربما تريدها
للقيام بذلك بشكل خاص ، لذا ربما في DMS
لأنني سأتصل بهم كما أنت
وأحاول الحصول على معلوماتك ، أعتقد أن
الشيء الأكثر أهمية هو أنني
لن ألومك ضحية
نعم متأكد من وجود أشياء  قبعة يمكنك
القيام بها لجعل وظيفتي أصعب قليلاً في
النهاية ، تقع على
عاتق الشركة مسؤولية الحفاظ على
بيانات عملائها آمنة وتحديث
بروتوكولات المصادقة الخاصة بهم عبر الهاتف
هي طريقة جيدة حقًا للبدء.
سعيد لأنني
وافقت على